das thema sport gehabt das heißt einmal
gleich drei leistungsgruppen alt war und
dann nochmal bisher laufen der von der
lok sei aber nur ein stück laufen dann
mit denen man dann ist der schaden durch
bis wieder zurückzukommen
[Musik]
ich muss mal zugesprochen
hier hätte man ersten wochen und schießt
den stopp der hormone und gelernt bei
der waffen die sicherheit überprüft und
wenn man es auseinandernimmt und
zusammensetzt dann als erster ins
porsche hatte findet sich hier
zurückziehen
genau und dann kann man von tieren zu
schwenken
[Musik]
quito auf die gehäuse sperre drauf und
dann noch als krassen rucksack packen
und mit den verschiedenen kampfanzug
varianten austreten für die schweren war
das jetzt stressig für die stärker
wächst
wir machen jetzt die antriebsarten das
war richtig rockt das stört mich
[Musik]
kozak versorgen die katze drei tore aus
dessen zeit eine minute
er ist eigentlich relativ schwach
die und varianten und natürlich fremden
setzt auf verlängerte wochenende
[Musik]